oh hello see Z's world my name is khan
aqui and i will be taking over this
channel for the month of october during
this time i will be uploading every
sunday so listen up closely because he
hears what you'll be getting we'll start
off with a web series called true fear
in which CZ will be telling you about
the horrors of the real world you'll
also be getting a new short horror film
entitled remote threat then you'll be
getting another new web series called al
dente creepypasta which is exactly what
it sounds like to finish up this month
i'll be releasing a brand-new episode of
the walking dead so be sure to look out
for that at the end of the month i'll be
returning CZ to you it turns out that he
was not very tasty at all the one you do
get him back things are going to be a
little bit different I've done a little
bargaining with CZ and when he comes
back he'll be uploading videos every two
weeks well I've got a lot to do this
month so I better get to it but before I
leave let me just say one more thing
let's go cubbies
you